welcome back here we're continuing now
our morning cup of joe interview with
Sheriff Joe Lombardo we've been talking
about the protests we talked about the
incident involving George Floyd in
Minneapolis his death at the hands of
Minneapolis Police and we also talked
about the shooting of officer the
officer on Monday night as well here in
town yes we want to go back though to
the protests which are continuing now
for several days here in Las Vegas
Sheriff thank you again for being with
us
governor Steve selected call in the
National Guard to assist with protests
here last night in Las Vegas has enough
been done to assist your officers out
these protests yeah at least so uh you
know interesting you talked about the
National Guard and I you know I followed
the press stream just like anybody else
because I head of an agency needs to
know what's going on with the
temperature is of the community and and
I see there's something some criticism
of the governor and his win and if he
was going to call the National Guard and
I think the general public has a
misconception on that type of element
when it comes to protests and assistance
and police agencies yes it is it's
valuable to have a human being and
numbers to assist you because the
protester is quite often out number of
the police officers which is not a
problem at face value but the National
Guard coming in is not a panacea by any
means because they don't train for this
these type of incidents they're not used
to engaging the general public in these
type of situations because that's not
what their expertise is or whatever
their specialty is in the military's is
what they're trained to do so we bring
them in is basically a force multiplier
in our situation we utilize them more
even a security apparatus than anything
else than a versus our one-on-one
interaction with the general public they
can assist us in securing our properties
and our equipment such as our vehicles
and all that stuff that doesn't doesn't
mean I'm trying to diminish their
ability or what we need to use them for
is just that we don't train together
that's very important for people to
understand for us to understand how
they're gonna react in a volatile
situation how we're going to react what
is the standard of the law that
they have two parameters or if they
restrict it with so we try to utilize
them the best authority that is given to
them and I don't want to again
administer their help and their support
it's it's wanted and it has been
provided by the governor and we're
utilizing that resource I just want
people out there to know that it's not
the panacea in the solution to
everything that we deal with we have
seen a lot of peaceful protests here in
Las Vegas and as we've talked about some
in some cases they haven't been
unfortunately a lot of videos
circulating and people chiming in on
social media Sheriff as they do wanted
to ask you what the threshold is when
officers determine when the protest
needs to be ended by force or to
disperse the crowd well that's a good
question and it's a asked quite often
during these type of incidents and there
is no answer Alex it depends on the
actions and the counter actions of each
side of the fence so when I mean by that
we fully intend to allow people to
protest or demonstrate or express their
views and communicate and everything
they do in those type of situations and
I guess per se the threshold would be is
when they start to endanger the general
public the people that are outside of
the demonstrators or even the
demonstrators themselves and or law
enforcement with that being said there's
a dispersal order when say the the
commander of that particular incident
makes a decision a this is starting to
get dangerous or impeding the general
public and their ability to go about
their lives there they're causing harm
by throwing rocks bottles missiles
anything you want to describe in that
effect and it's time for us to provide a
dispersal order and time for them to
move on and cease the event and what I
mean by the dispersal order is it's a
verbal personal orders given by a
commander out on the scene usually be a
bullhorn and it has to be three times
with ten minutes in between each other
so about thirty minutes
they give the people the opportunity to
lead they've been warmed sufficiently
it's time for you to leave and go about
your business and what has happened in
that anatomy of these protests a day
over day is eventually make the decision
it's time to disperse them we give the
dispersal orders and that's when the
rocks and everything else start to fly
with our zest I would to say so at that
point we identify the key agitators and
attempt to get them into custody and
hope to quell the violence that's what
happened with officer Michael anus you
know at that point we gave the dispersal
order we wanted people to put into
custody and then the tragic events
associated with that
well sheriff you mentioned when those
arrests take place that the officers try
and look for the the agitators we've
we've seen a lot of arrests that have
taken place we've seen the use of tear
gas a pepper spray
not only at in some cases peaceful
members of the protest but also members
of the media are are you at all somewhat
concerned critical or are you pleased
with the actions it's some of the more
highly charged moments of these protests
well that's a good good point but here's
here's a deal a lot of times when you've
seen that there's a perception maybe
they're peaceful or they're docile you
usually don't see the back end of what's
taking place prior to the effect of the
rest but including the net even though
it may have perception that they're
docile and they're not the ones actually
throwing the rocks per se they might be
encompassed in the dispersal order so by
the fact that they're remaining in place
refusing to move they may be part of
that group and and once the disperse
order is given and it's and you have not
let left you are violating the law and
that's basically failure to disperse so
those journalists that's you are or
pining on or discussing or describing
they were caught up in that type of fray
and so the officers didn't have the
ability to determine whether they were
journalists at the time this is what I
my understanding you know the answer
obviously a playout record I'm sure but
that was part of that type of incident
or they're caught in the frame they
refused
those first orders sheriff in the last
segment you talked about some of the
black guys from Metro Police in the past
there have been efforts to try and
address that through federal court
procedures the ACLU etc in the community
if one of the the crux of some of these
protests is is social justice equality
and and police accountability some would
suggest our still issues with Metro when
it comes to public records when it comes
to dealing with some members of the
community use of certain kinds of choke
holds and other efforts within the
department don't those also have to be
addressed in order to sort of try and
appease all parts of the community yeah
you're absolutely right and you haven't
described or said one particular type of
issue that we haven't addressed or we
haven't freedom compromised or got in
discussion with or disgusting the court
system on each one of those so I don't
think as an organization we've missed
any particular incident or type of the
policy or procedure that we need to
address and when I say black I yeah
you're exactly right we failed to act
previously but in today's age and in
current time I think we've been pretty
successful and a lot of that is
cooperation with the public and dealing
with outside organizations to develop
that compromise and I'm very proud of
our robust relationship with the
community in particular communities of
different races and cultures the metric
metro multicultural Advisory Committee
has been in place and it has very robust
power within my organization what they
quite often bring those particular type
issues forward and we're happy to
discuss with them compromise and change
how we do business
sheriff we only have a few seconds left
but want to ask you really quickly a lot
of resorts on the strip are reopening
tomorrow
how will Metro be involved with this
especially as these protests continue
well first and foremost
I have to applaud that they're opening I
think we need it I think people need a
released economy needs a release and you
know one of them unfortunate things of
us there's their civil and I would say
sober arrest is this this protests and
demonstrations is the code of nineteen
is fall on the backside and I think
people have lost sight of that it's
still out there and we have to address
it continuing to move in forward but
with that said I'm glad the resorts are
opening we've been in constant
conversation with their security
apparatus as a police department should
be in these type of situations we're
given advice both ways on how we should
do this going forward in conjunction
with the Gaming Control Board and all
the preventive measures put on on the
floor space of these casinos so I guess
to answer your question Alex it's been a
robust communication back and forth and
hopefully we're gonna be back with
success here tomorrow upon the grand
openings and then that our economy has a
release for our local residents inspires
unemployment and anxiety and everything
else that we deal with on a daily basis
as a community which may be part and
parcel to some of the frustration of
people participating in these
demonstrations and we're not you're all
about mr. Floyd on its own and social
injustice on its own it may be about
just what the hell is going on in our
lives here recently all right sheriff we
are all out of time unfortunately thanks
for taking a time we appreciate it and
we send our very best to officer Michael
onus thank you very much